alors c'est mon petit papier
donc de la délégation aux outre-mer et
connecter donc je le salue à distance je
ne sais même pas quelle heure est-il à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon mais il est 4
heures du matin à bon c'est un matinal
voilà
donc c'est pour ça que peut-être qu'on
le voit pas l'image c'est plus compliqué
voilà donc chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs monsieur pardon nous tenons ce
matin notre dernière audition plénière
consacrée à la parentalité dans les
territoires outre-mer depuis le début de
l'année nous menons des travaux sur
cette thématique avec deux délégations
la délégation aux outre-mer et qui
présidait par Stéphane Artano et la
délégation en droit des femmes que j'ai
l'honneur de préciser outre outre les
présidents des deux délégations sont
également rapporteurs victoires jasmin
sénatrice de la Guadeloupe qui va nous
rejoindre et ils achalke excusées ce
matin sénatrice du Bas-Rhin nous
entendons ce matin Anne Morvan Paris
sous directrice de l'enfance et de la
famille à la direction générale de la
cohésion sociale accompagnée d'Alix
comme moi référente outre-mer pour la
DGCS Jean-Marc bedon
coordinateur de projets référent
outre-mer la CNAF bienvenue également et
Isabelle Richard sous directrice des
politiques publiques à la direction
générale des Outre-mer bienvenue à vous
quatre monsieur mesdames nous attendent
ce matin s'articule principalement
autour de deux axes premièrement
comprendre des raisons qui expliquent la
persistance de différence dans les
prestations servies dans les outre-mer
et dans l'Hexagone et savoir si certains
rapprochements sont envisagés ou
envisageables je pense notamment aux
complément familial dans les dromes
historiques et aux règles spécifiques
qui s'appliquent à Mayotte par exemple
quel serait le coût d'un alignement de
cette prestation sur le sujet des
prestations familiales nous nous
interrogeons également sur la bonne
connaissance de leurs droits par les
familles des Outre-mer le taux de non
recours au droit est-il plus élevé que
dans l'Hexagone
ce taux diffère-t-il par ailleurs en
fonction des territoires
ultramarins quelles actions menez-vous
afin d'améliorer l'accès aux droits nous
avons par ailleurs été alertés sur les
idées fausses que ce qui circule
concernant les effets de la
reconnaissance des enfants par leur père
comment les dissiper et inciter les
paires à reconnaître leurs enfants en
effet aux Antilles et en Guyane deux
tiers des enfants ne sont aujourd'hui
pas reconnus par leur père à leur
naissance notre deuxième axe de
discussion ce matin concerne les
dispositifs de soutien à la parentalité
au sens strict les actions des cas
flocales ont été salués par les
différents interlocuteurs que nous avons
auditionné au Sénat ou rencontrer lors
d'un déplacement en Guadeloupe cependant
des difficultés en matière de
coordination et un manque de moyens
financiers humains nous ont été signalés
lors de la détermination des budgets
accord des Outre-mer une prise en compte
de la précarité de la population
couverte est-elle possible des
financesment structurelles aux
associations sont-ils également
envisageables par ailleurs comment
assurer un déploiement efficace de la
stratégie nationale de soutien à la
parentalité et du programme des 1000
premiers jours dans tous les territoires
des outre-mer et comment améliorer la
coordination entre les acteurs
institutionnels et les associations en
la matière vous avez en outre reçu un
questionnaire pour lesquels nous
attendons des réponses pour le 12 juin
puisque nous allons rendre nos travaux
prochainement donc ce serait mieux
d'avoir les réponses avant de rendre nos
conclusions je laisse sans plus tarder
la parole à Anne Morvan Paris pour la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale à vous madame
oui bonjour madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur le Président même si on ne vous
voit pas mais on vous devine
je vais intervenir principalement sur le
soutien la parentalité dans les
autres-mères en rappelant que ce soutien
la parentalité devenu une politique
publique à part entière avec la parution
de la charte de soutien la parentalité
début 2022 et un ensemble de dispositifs
depuis quelques années qui se traduisent
à la fois dans la politique des 1000
jours mais aussi dans un certain nombre
de de dispositifs portés principalement
évidemment par la branche famille mais
aussi par l'État et par les
collectivités locales soutenues dans des
programmes par l'État
il est vrai que c'est un enjeu majeur ce
soutient la parentalité puisque au
regard des déterminants sociaux
économiques que vous avez pu percevoir
depuis vos auditions qui sont des enjeux
particuliers au territoire d'outre-mer
notamment le nombre élevé de familles
monoparentales et la question aussi des
violences intrafamilales cette question
de du soutien la parentalité est un
enjeu de prévention avant tout et de
pouvoir aider les familles dans des
moments parfois où elles peuvent se
trouver en difficulté
on a évidemment des situations très
variables d'un territoire à l'autre et
tout au long de vos auditions et par
rapport aux données démographiques
notamment vous avez pu en effet
constater des réalités qui sont très
différentes mais par contre on a constat
commun c'est que les caractéristiques
socio-économiques sont plus défavorables
sur l'ensemble des territoires que celle
de la métropole et nous avons notamment
des indicateurs sur le niveau
d'éducation et sur les taux de pauvreté
qui sont à prendre en compte dans cette
politique de soutien à la parentalité
je vais pas reprendre l'ensemble des
chiffres que vous connaissez je vais
peut-être me concentrer plutôt sur le
programme des 1000 premiers jours qui en
fait quand on parle de programme des
1000 premiers jours on est sur une
stratégie large c'est l'ensemble des
acteurs à la fois nationaux et locaux
qui sont mobilisés autour de cette ce
principe que les 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfance déterminants ils sont
déterminants pour l'enfant et pour sa
famille il y a un consensus scientifique
et ça c'était un point important et de
se consensus scientifique un certain
nombre d'actions étaient déployés à la
fois pour pour soutenir les familles dès
la des la maternité enfin même des à
avant avant la naissance et puis tout au
long des deux premières années de la
ville de l'enfant et là je vais aborder
la question de comment cela s'est
déployer sur les dromes et quels sont
les améliorations qu'on peut apporter en
tout cas de ces nos réflexions après la
mise en œuvre de ces déploiement la
feuille de route mais le premier jour
la première chose c'est que
contrairement peut-être à des des
risques que l'on pouvait avoir sur le
fait que les territoires d'outre-mer se
saisissent bien de cette politique il y
a eu un certain nombre d'actions qui ont
pu être déployés
tout d'abord les outils âge auprès des
parents comme le livret des 1000
premiers jours a pu être diffuser à
partir de 2021
il y a notamment la RS Martinique qui
s'en est servi comme support un certain
nombre de formations et d'informations
auprès des des professionnels pour
pouvoir aussi l'expliquer au mieux aux
familles
sur le sujet sur la question de
l'entretien prénatal précoce qui est un
vrai enjeu en de prévention les taux de
réalisation sont aujourd'hui très
proches du niveau métropolitain en
Martinique Guadeloupe et réunions et
c'est de sur la Guyane et Mayotte qui
sont on le sait de territoires
particulièrement
exposés aux questions de
d'accompagnement de la natalité que que
ces chiffres sont aujourd'hui très très
inférieurs et que les efforts doivent
être portés la Guyane a cependant mais a
été territoire expérimentateur au niveau
national d'un référent parcours
périnatalité avec l'idée de pouvoir
accompagner des parcours renforcés
notamment autour de repérage de
violences ou de vulnérabilité psychique
et enfin la Réunion fait partie des 8
café expérimentatrices des groupes
naissance avec un parcours naissance
partagé avec la CPAM
concernant le déploiement des 1000
premiers jours sur la le repérage des
vulnérabilités un des gros dispositifs
qui s'est déployés au niveau national et
dans les dromes ce sont les staffs
médicaux psychosociaux c'est à dire de
pouvoir appuyer de la des la maternité
un accompagnement de la de la maman
particulier sur un enjeu psy et social
des moyens ont été déployés une
enveloppe de 400.000 euros notamment de
2021 et 200 000 en 2022
il s'agit en fait de pouvoir
éviter que la détresse psychologique de
la de la maman impacte évidemment son
lien avec l'enfant dès le plus jeune âge
concernant l'allongement du congé
paternité le nombre de recours a été
plus important enfin c'est vraiment
déployé dans les dans les dromes on a
aujourd'hui selon les territoires entre
25 et 69% de recours
à ce congé paternité alors l'objectif de
80% n'est pas atteint mais en tout cas
il y a eu un réel progrès sur ce congé
paternité on pourra vous donner dans nos
dans nos rapports écrits le détail de ce
recours dans chacun des territoires et
puis il y avait une
contre-actualisation côté protection de
l'enfance mais surtout un appel à projet
des 1000 premiers jours trois
territoires s'en sont saisis ont permis
de déployer localement un centre
d'action notamment avec le secteur
associatif que vous évoquiez et qui a
permis notamment de d'appuyer un certain
nombre de projets pour aller vers les
les familles et aller au plus près des
[Musique]
notamment des mamans dans les familles
monopar entales pour pour les
accompagner vers une vers une meilleure
prise en compte de leur de leurs
difficultés
aujourd'hui le constat après trois ans
de déploiement c'est que sur le la
stratégie 1000 premiers jours il n'y a
pas une stratégie spécifique ou de Rome
ça a été fait sa stratégie s'est
déployée de la même manière que sur le
territoire le reste du territoire
national et la question aujourd'hui
puisque nous sommes dans la deuxième
feuille de route des 1000 premiers jours
que nous sommes en train d'écrire c'est
de s'interroger sur une déclinaison
renforcée spécifique au drone ou de Rome
avec la question notamment de
l'adaptation de tous les outils on s'est
rendu compte que par exemple le livret
devait peut-être nécessiter une
traduction et un accompagnement dans les
différentes langues créoles et autres
sur le les différents territoires
en tout cas qu'il devait y avoir
certainement une déclinaison adaptée à
la à l'environnement culturel de chacun
de ces territoires qui est très
différente évidemment entre entre
Mayotte et par exemple la Guyane sur
outils il s'agit aussi de pouvoir
adapter le sac des 1000 premiers jours
et de pouvoir le mieux le déployer dans
les maternités en outre-mer
c'est un des enjeux du de
l'inscription notamment budgétaire pour
et puis d'avoir des milieux des lieux
ressources de proximité puisque
aujourd'hui le constat c'est que
les familles finalement ce sont les plus
éloignées de ces outils alors qu'elles
en ont le plus besoin n'arrive pas à
trouver la bonne porte et donc le
déploiement des maisons de 1000 premiers
jours et la mise en réseau d'acteurs à
échelle territoriale devient nécessaire
et donc la déclinaison sur le territoire
ultramarins de ces de ces différents
outils et de les adapter est une serait
un des voilà une des priorités du de la
future feuille de route
concernant les parents et l'approche
directe des familles il faut
certainement s'attacher à adapter le
parcours des sens et de pouvoir
certainement créer des fonds
et CNAM pour financer des actions
locales et c'est là où on retrouve le
sujet de la de pouvoir mieux travailler
avec les associations et les et les
partenaires qui connaissent les familles
qui sont plus près d'elles qui peuvent
notamment
faire une un rôle de médiation et de
faire venir les familles sur sur les
différents dispositifs c'est à dire
d'avoir du droit commun et puis si c'est
nécessaire adapter ce droit commun avec
du droit spécifique et des démarches
notamment de d'accès aux droits adaptés
enfin on
estime que sur la prochaine vague des
1000 premiers jours il faudra être plus
actif sur
les métiers de la PMI et sur la question
autour de la maternité et d'être
d'envisager des soutiens financiers
spécifiques soit dans le cas de la
contractualisation
protection de l'enfance avec le fear
soit dans des dispositifs portés
notamment par la CNAM pour des bilans
notamment de prévention réalisé par des
sages-femmes pendant la grossesse
enfin peut-être dernier point
d'attention sur ce déploiement des 1000
premiers jours
il faut
en tout cas s'assurer que ce déploiement
se fasse de la même manière sur
l'ensemble des territoires aujourd'hui
on a des territoires qui sont plus en
retrait alors que les besoins sont
certains les plus importants évidemment
Mayotte et pleinement concernée parce
que j'évoque comment on peut faire pour
que en tout cas
apporter des compétences alors est-ce
que c'est développer localement des
compétences et les appuyer apporter
aussi des compétences du de la métropole
vers vers les maternités
ultramarines en tout cas
ce sujet des ressources locales et de
l'appui à ses ressources locales est un
vrai un vrai enjeu avec la volonté
d'avoir une unité d'hospitalisation par
un bébé en spécialisé en psychiatrie
Paris natale à terme c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et cet enjeu de pouvoir en
tout cas identifier que chaque
territoire bénéficie du même du même
type de structure et important
et pour et ça rejoint notamment des
sujets que vous avez déjà évoqués dans
un certain nombre d'auditions qui est la
plus à l'ingénierie et l'ingénierie de
projet sur sur un certain nombre de
territoires
ultramarins ils sont évidemment pas tous
aujourd'hui avec la même qualité de
structuration de cette ingénierie
peut-être sur un dernier point qui était
celui de la coordination des acteurs
depuis un an des comités départements
toute services aux familles se déploient
sur l'ensemble des départements français
c'est une manière de pouvoir animer en
tout cas localement c'est cette
politique à la fois de politique de mode
de garde de l'enfant mais aussi de la
parentalité ça fait partie de la
démission qui sont dans ces comité de
service aux familles les territoires
ultramarins ont demandé d'avoir une
allège un allègement de la structuration
de ces comités de services aux familles
puisque aujourd'hui il faut ils sont
composés de plus de 40 membres et donc
ça rend difficile en fait leur mise en
place et le fait de pouvoir se réunir
régulièrement donc on pourra répondre en
effet
favorablement à cette demande
d'allègement et de pouvoir concrètement
être le plus opérationnel possible pour
qu'autour du préfet du président du
département et du président de la de la
CAF locale les enjeux de parentalité et
de services aux familles puissent être
analysés et puisse pouvoir être
développer les outils les plus
pertinents je sais que mes collègues de
la CNAV reviendront sur notamment le
fond parentalité qui a un des outils de
développement
je suis évidemment à votre disposition
pour toute question complémentaires et
revenir sur un certain nombre de points
si nécessaire
merci beaucoup donc je vais laisser la
parole comme vous le souhaitez ensuite
comment vous organisez
oui oui donc c'est Monsieur Jean-Marc
bedon qui va intervenir à la suite
effectivement
donc je précise que vous êtes
coordinateur de projets référents
outre-mer à la CNAV ça vous laisse le
temps de boire un petit verre
quelques mots quelques mois en
introduction peut-être pour réaffirmer
l'attention particulière de la Caisse
nationale des allocations familiales en
faveur des territoires d'outre-mer et
des CAF des départements et régions
d'outre-mer
en effet les contextes économiques et
sociaux de ces territoires mais aussi
leur histoire regarde l'égalité des
droits que vous pointiez tout à l'heure
madame la Présidente notamment droit au
titre des prestations sociales versées
par les cafs justifie depuis la création
des caves
la mobilisation et un dialogue de
proximité entre la CNAV et C4 pour
accompagner au mieux leurs missions et
faciliter le déploiement de leurs
actions au profit des populations
un bref rappel également concernant les
limites géographiques du périmètre
d'intervention et de responsabilité de
la branche famille en faveur des
territoires d'outre-mer les territoires
d'exercices de la CNAV et des caves
concernent les départements de la
réunion de Mayotte de la Guyane de la
Martinique et de la Guadeloupe mais
aussi des deux collectivités
territoriales de Saint Martin et
Saint-Barthélémy qui sont couvertes par
la cave de la Guadeloupe ainsi
l'ensemble des autres collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas dans le champ
de responsabilité de la Caisse nationale
et donc des cafés
sur cet ensemble géographique néanmoins
quelques chiffres maintenant permettant
peut-être de mesurer un peu l'action des
cas ultramarines et de caractériser les
allocataires
ultramarins en 2022 les 5 caisses
d'outre-mer on versait des prestations à
590 000 foyers à locataire représentant
1,4 millions de personnes de manière
plus parlante peut-être le taux de
couverture de la population par les cafs
et de 63%, soit les deux tiers de la
population
ultramarine
par comparaison le taux moyen de
couverture des cafés
cette sur-représentation de la place des
cafs en matière de couverture des
populations dans les dromes concernent
toutes les prestations
pour ne prendre que quatre exemples 74%
de la population et bénéficiaires des
allocations familiales contre 62% en
métropole
les foyers monoparentaux bénéficiaires
de la location de soutien familial
représente 15% des allocataires contre
seulement 6% en métropole ou encore
concernant le RSA un allocateur sur
trois et bénéficiaire dans les dromes
pour seulement un allocateur sur 10 en
métropole
enfin pour un tiers des allocataires les
prestations versées par la cave
constituent leur seul ressources de
revenus pour vivre
cette proportion est deux fois plus
élevée qu'en métropole ou 17% des
allocataires sont dans cette situation
ce taux élevé de dépendance aux
prestations et certainement le plus
révélateur des difficultés sociales de
ces territoires il engage au quotidien
la responsabilité de la Caisse nationale
et des caisses d'allocations familiales
ultramarines qui assume de manière
encore plus prégnante que sur le reste
du territoire national un rôle
d'amortisseur social
en effet les prestations familiales et
sociales leur poids financier leur
caractère redistributif et de
solvabilisation des familles constituent
des leviers importants des politiques
publiques de lutte contre les inégalités
mais aussi de cohésion sociale aussi
bien à l'échelle locale que nationale
enfin pour être totalement complet sur
ce sujet de précision peut-être la
première concerne le poids financier de
cette redistribution dont je viens de
faire mention le total annuel des
prestations légales versées par les cafs
des dromes s'élèvent à 463 millions
d'euros sur un budget global France
entière d'environ 100 milliards d'euros
deuxième précision concernant l'état du
droit en matière de prestation
si durant en effet de nombreuses années
les droits aux prestations comportaient
de multiples différences entre les
outre-mer et la métropole on peut
souligner aujourd'hui à l'exception du
cas particulier de Mayotte que l'égalité
est quasiment réalisée sur le plan du
droit
et que toute nouvelle prestation légale
nationale est automatiquement applicable
et au même conditions dans les
départements d'outre-mer
quelques différences persistent
néanmoins elle concerne bien évidemment
les allocations familiales qui sont
versées dès le premier enfant dans les
outre-mer mais aussi l'allocation de
compléments familial également versé dès
le premier enfant
enfin dans le domaine du logement par
exemple les dominants locataires du parc
social conventionnées ne peuvent
bénéficier comment métropole d'une aide
personnalisée au logement en revanche
les accidents à la propriété dans les
outre-mer peuvent si leurs ressource le
permettent bénéficier d'une aide au
logement ce qui n'est plus le cas en
métropole depuis 2018
de même les drums bénéficient de deux
autres prestations qui n'existent pas en
métropole le revenu de solidarité et la
prestation accueil et restauration
scolaire
cette prestation permet au Cap
d'outre-mer de contribuer au financement
de la restauration scolaire dans le but
de réduire le reste à charge des
familles
en 2021 344
000 enfants scolarisés de la maternelle
au lycée ont bénéficié de cette aide
soit 64% de l'ensemble des élèves
ultramarins
il convient toutefois ici de souligner
la situation particulière de la Guyane
dont le taux de couverture et le plus
faible de l'ensemble des départements
d'outre-mer avec seulement 38% des
élèves bénéficiaires
cette moindre couverture étant partie
liée à l'absence de dispositif et
d'offres de restauration scolaire dans
plusieurs communes de la Guyane et la
CAF ne peut à elle seule au moyen de la
prestation financer une offre de
restauration scolaire dont
l'organisation la gestion et le
financement relève de la responsabilité
des collectivités
pour clore ce chapitre concernant les
prestations dans les outremerges je ne
peux passer je ne peux pas passer sous
silence évidemment l'action des CAF en
matière d'accès aux droits qui est
évidemment un enjeu majeur pour ces
territoires
dans ce cadre les caves peuvent
s'appuyer sur de nombreux leviers et
canaux de contacts pour agir en faveur
de l'accès aux droits
elles ont déployé une stratégie
proactive d'aller vers dans une approche
situationnelle et ont mis en place des
parcours usagers
comme par exemple le parcours séparation
depuis 2021 et elle déploie en
prochainement le parcours arrivée d'un
enfant dans la généralisation est prévue
à la fin de cette année ce nouveau
parcours vise à renforcer
l'accompagnement des parents de la
grossesse jusqu'au 3 ans de l'enfant
c'est parcours déclenchés des
connaissances par la caisse d'un
événement vise à faciliter les démarches
des usagers et à valoriser les droits
aux prestations mais aussi à informer
orienté et accompagner les allocataires
vers les dispositifs aident et services
d'action sociale proche de chez eux et
pouvant être mobilisés en réponse à leur
situation
l'écart dans les cartes d'outre-mer ont
également développé des formats
d'accueil spécifique comme des
rendez-vous des droits qui sont proposés
à des allocataires en situation sociale
à risque là aussi l'objectif est
d'informer si besoin de conseiller et
surtout de veiller à ce que l'ensemble
des droits auxquels les allocataires
peuvent prétendre soient bien valorisés
les caves s'appuient également sur le
développement d'un large réseau de
partenaires pour mailler le territoire
et proposer une information de premiers
niveaux et un accompagnement notamment
numérique il peut s'agir d'espace France
services de CCAS de permanence de mairie
ou encore de structures partenaires
comme des musiques comme des maisons des
parents ou des centres sociaux
enfin est contenu de leur géographie
particulière les cafs des dômes ont
développé des solutions innovantes
mobiles et itinérantes permettant
d'aller au contact des populations je
pense
au territoire de l'Intérieur en Guyane
ou ou aux villes et aux communes des
hauts à la Réunion par exemple
et donc des solutions itinérantes
permettant d'aller au plus proche des
populations
ces initiatives au croisement de l'accès
aux droits et du développement
territorial des offres de services des
cafs m'amène également à vous dire
quelques mots sur l'action tout aussi
essentielle des caves des dômes en
faveur des politiques sociales sur ces
territoires
pour contribuer aux politiques publiques
et développer leur mission les câbles
disposent de plusieurs leviers
financiers et de dispositifs
conventionnels stratégiques et
opérationnels de partenariat
s'agissant des leviers financiers les
caves disposent de dotation d'action
sociale plus généralement appelé font
locaux à la disposition des conseils
d'administration des CAF
et des pensées dans le cadre de
règlement intérieur qui sont définis par
chacune des caisses départementales
mais aussi les cas disposent de
fondations dédiés comme le font national
parentalité par exemple et de
prestations services qui permettent aux
caves de contribuer au développement et
au fonctionnement des équipements
déployants des services aux familles et
des actions sociales d'accompagnement
des populations
le Front national parentalité justement
a été créé en 2014 spécifiquement pour
aider les cafs à soutenir le déploiement
des actions des réseaux d'écoute et
d'accompagnement des parents le réseau
des Reap
mais aussi pour financer des postes de
coordinateur animateurs de la
gouvernance partenariale locale des
acteurs du soutien à la parentalité et
depuis 2022 un nouvel axe est venu
enrichir le Front national parentalité
afin de pouvoir financer des lieux
d'accueil et de ressources des familles
sur les questions liées à la parentalité
comme par exemple les maisons des 1000
premiers jours
et financer le développement de services
d'écoute personnalisées et
d'Accompagnement des Parents à distance
les financements apportés aux
gestionnaires de services ou opérateurs
de projets s'inscrivent généralement
sauf dans des cas de projets très
ponctuels dans le cadre de conventions
de partenariat et de financement plus
riches annuel qui couvre aujourd'hui
entre 3 et 4 ans et nous avons une
perspective et un objectif dans notre
prochaine période conventionnelle
2023-2027 d'élargir encore cette
pluriennuité à 5 ans
qui permettra effectivement à l'ensemble
des opérateurs et partenaires de
s'inscrire dans la durée relative à leur
fonctionnement
s'agissant du cadre stratégique et
opérationnel l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarins se sont dotés d'un schéma
départemental des services aux familles
dans lesquels les CAF occupent une large
place ce cadre de gouvernance réunit les
différents échelons des collectivités du
territoire les services des centralisés
de l'État et les principaux principaux
opérateurs de terrain et cette
gouvernance est essentielle pour définir
les axes prioritaires d'intervention au
regard des diagnostics des besoins
sociaux des familles et des territoires
pour structurer coordonner la mise en
oeuvre des actions et enfin pour
mobiliser l'adhésion et l'engagement de
chacun en matière de co-financement des
projets et des services
le cadre stratégique des sdsf
s'accompagne pour les CAF d'un autre
support cadre de partenariat mais cette
fois-ci à l'échelle communale ou
intercommunal il s'agit des conventions
territoriales globales
qui permettent de définir de manière
très opérationnelle les objectifs et les
actions à mettre en œuvre pour répondre
aux besoins sociaux des familles et
mailler les territoires
fin 2022 81 conventions territorielle
territoriales pardon globale couvrant 62
communes ont été signées par les cafs
d'outre-mer avec leur partenaire
communaux
ces conventions de partenariat traitent
et figuent des objectifs d'action sur de
nombreux domaines bien entendu la petite
enfance l'enfance la jeunesse mais aussi
la vie sociale l'inclusion handicap le
travail social la précarité et la lutte
contre la pauvreté l'accès aux droits le
logement la santé la vieillesse la
citoyenneté ou encore le développement
durable
sur ces bases contractuelles et
particulièrement en matière de soutien
la parentalité les caps des Outre-mer en
lien avec la CNAV ce sont mobilisés dans
les années 2018-2022 avec l'objectif
principal de renforcer le maillage des
offres de services et des actions de
soutien à la parentalité notamment dans
une visière dans une visée de prévention
des exclusions sociales et des
situations à risque
pour ce faire les quatre on devrait sur
l'ensemble des territoires à l'émergence
ou à la consolidation des services de
médiation familiale par exemple
aujourd'hui 11 équipements hors Mayotte
sont en fonctionnement et en activité
sur l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer mais aussi des structures
proposant des lieux d'accueil enfant par
an tous les départements aujourd'hui
disposent d'une offre elles ont
également contribué à la création et au
soutien de 11 espaces de rencontres
enfin 108 actions d'accompagnement à la
scolarité ont été déployés en faveur des
enfants et de leurs parents ainsi que de
nombreux actions d'accompagnement à la
parentalité soutenue dans le cadre des
Reap
de même en 2021 le panier de service
jargon institutionnel mais qui consiste
à assurer un minima sur un EPCI une
offre d'accompagnement à la scolarité
plus une offre d'accompagnement à la
parentalité et de garantir enfin le
fonctionnement d'un lieu d'accueil
enfant par an
et bien l'ensemble des EPCI de la
Martinique et de la Réunion
ont mis en place le panier de service du
côté de la Guadeloupe 50% des EPCI se
sont dotés de ce panier de service et
simplement 25% en Guyane
le soutien la parentalité déployé par
les caves d'outre-mer c'est également
matérialisé par un renforcement et un
recentrage des interventions de traverss
sociaux des cafés des allocataires en
situation à risque 11000 foyers
allocataires ont ainsi bénéficié en 2020
d'un accompagnement social dispensé par
un travailleur social
84% des interventions de travail social
ont concerné des situations de divorce
ou de séparation et 16% restants des
interventions ont été mobilisées en
faveur des situations de décès d'un
conjoint ou d'un enfant d'un pays de
loyer ou pour soutenir des foyers
monoparentaux
enfin les cas ultramarines sont
fortement mobilisés pour soutenir la
création et le développement de
structures d'animation de la vie sociale
comme les centres sociales ou les
espaces de vie sociale entre 2018 et
2022 plus de 70 nouveaux équipements ont
été créés prioritairement dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville
ces équipements sont par leur ancrage
dans les quartiers au plus proche des
besoins du public ils sont pour les caps
des relais particulièrement pertinents
pour déployer des services et des
actions de soutien à la parentalité
toutefois et j'en terminerai là
les caves sont confrontés dans dans de
nombreux secteurs effectivement à
l'insuffisance de Coffe de
co-financement des partenaires limitant
de ce fait le rendement des leviers et
dispositifs de financement nationaux
à la disposition des cafs en effet de
nombreuses collectivités territoriales
font face à des situations financières
très concrètes et ne contribue pas ou
pas seuls ou pas suffisamment aux
co-financement des équipements tels que
prévu dans le cadre conventionnel des
outils nationaux de la branche famille
pour pallier ces situations les caves
sont contraintes de compléter les
prestations de service national par des
apports sur leur fonds locaux et ou par
des dispositifs ou mesures dérogatoires
ponctuelles validé par la CNAF visant à
bonifier l'apport financier au
gestionnaires des équipements et
services aux familles
dans le cadre des discussions en cours
entre la CNAV et les services de l'état
relatif aux orientations et aux moyens
de la branche pour la période 2023 2027
la CNAV porte en faveur des départements
d'outre-mer la proposition de soutenir
les projets et les fonctions le
fonctionnement des structures d'accueil
de la petite enfance et des services aux
familles en prenant en compte de manière
spécifique les problématiques de
cofinancement
et les besoins de rattrapage des
territoires les plus fragiles
identifiés notamment dans le cadre des
schémas départementaux des services aux
familles et bien entendu les territoires
d'outre-mer comptent parmi les
territoires les plus fragiles
de même il est proposé de poursuivre le
développement du mariage territorial
notamment des quartiers prioritaires de
la politique de la ville restant non
couvert aujourd'hui par des structures
d'animation de la vie sociale
par ailleurs au-delà de la problématique
de financement et vous l'avez pointé
madame la Présidente
les caves sont confrontés à un certain
déficit ou une faiblesse d'opérateurs et
de structures assises sur des modèles
économiques viables et en capacité de
mettre en oeuvre des offres de service
d'action sociale
et ce point constitue certainement le
second trait majeur caractérisant les
freins au développement des politiques
sociales des caves ultramarines dans de
nombreux secteurs d'intervention en
effet les caves doivent assumer parfois
intégralement l'ingénierie sociale
nécessaire à l'émergence d'opérateurs et
à la création d'offres de services
j'entends formation des professionnels
mobilisation des partenaires montage
financiers de projets et des services
recherche de locaux structuration des
acteurs et des réseaux relais des cafés
assurer l'accompagnement au quotidien
des opérateurs gestionnaires des
services et des familles merci
bien merci beaucoup monsieur
pour cette présentation comme la
première d'ailleurs tout à fait
exhaustive et intéressante et je vais
passer la parole à notre dernière
intervenante madame Isabelle Richard
sous directrice des politiques publiques
à la direction générale des Outre-mer
c'est à vous madame merci madame
monsieur
comme vous voulez c'est pour qu'on
entende bien c'est tout
rapprochez-vous de Monsieur bedon si
vous le souhaitez
madame madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur le Président également que nous
connaissons bien de la délégation
sanatoriale aux outre-mer
je vais être bien sûr complémentaire X
de ma collègue de la DGCS et bien sûr de
Monsieur de Monsieur bedon dans mes
propos
rapidement en introduction je voulais
évidemment indiquer que la parentalité
est un défi pour pour chacun pour chaque
parent qu'il soit dans l'Hexagone dans
les autres mères ou partout dans le
monde finalement mais ce défi peut
apparaître encore plus vertigineux en
outre-mer au regard d'un certain nombre
de constats de caractéristiques que je
crois bien sûr vous avez parfaitement
pris la mesure au fur et à mesure de vos
auditions la part des familles parent
monoparentales et parfois jusqu'à trois
fois supérieur à ce taux hexagonale les
naissances précoces sont également plus
nombreuses elles atteignent
10,2% Guyane dans le dernier recensement
connu en 2018 entre 2,1% en métropole
les conditions de vie sont aussi plus
difficiles avec un chômage plus élevé
bien que le taux de chômage soit en
diminution dans la plupart des
territoires depuis un an ils sont suit
puisque en fait les deux sont fortement
corrélés
au regard du taux de chômage il en
résulte un taux de pauvreté inquiétant
trop important et qui culmine bien sûr à
Mayotte avec 77% de taux de pauvreté les
prix sont également plus plus élevés ce
qui est évidemment un souci pour pour
les parents même si l'inflation et moins
élevée depuis un an et enfin dans cette
revue de constat de spécificités de
différence l'illettrisme et
l'électronisme est aussi beaucoup sont
aussi beaucoup plus élevés outre-mer
avec par exemple un taux de 30% en
Guadeloupe ce qui amène évidemment des
difficultés pour les parents pour
pour faire valoir leur droit ou pour
exercer leurs parentalité au quotidien
c'est quelques chiffres pour indiquer
également qu'effectivement la
parentalité mais même si je vais revenir
assez enjeux de se limite pas aux enjeux
d'éducation et de soins aux enfants mais
c'est un problématique bien bien globale
qu'il faut prendre dans sa dans sa
totalité dans notamment dans les
soutiens que l'on apporte aux familles
et aussi en premier lieu sans doute aux
familles monoparentales de ce point de
vue il y a un enjeu particulier pour
aider ces familles à continuer
ces femmes donc de ce fait pour aider
ces femmes à continuer à se former à
continuer à avoir un emploi c'est
vraiment aussi un moyen de rompre sans
doute un cercle vicieux puisque
effectivement les statistiques montrent
en dans l'Hexagone comme outre-mer
qu'effectivement de statistiquement il y
a une corrélation entre le fait pour les
le fait pour la
femme d'avoir eu
d'avoir elle-même été
issue d'une famille monoparentale et
d'être ou d'être d'avoir un niveau de
formation peservé d'être pauvre il y a
une corrélation entre ces phénomènes et
puis le fait de reproduire également ce
schéma de famille monoparentale en
Suisse donc il y a vraiment tout un
enjeu de de formation d'accompagnement
notamment des jeunes filles ou des
jeunes femmes des jeunes mères et de ce
point de vue il est important de
soutenir un certain nombre d'actions par
exemple en Guyane les dates ont organisé
des formations s'adressant aux jeunes
aux jeunes maires permettant à celle-ci
d'avoir un mode de garde à proximité de
leur lieu de formation ou permettant
aussi à ces jeunes maires d'avoir un
moyen de locomotion pour se rendre à
leur lieu de formation le service
militaire adapté qui est aussi une
spécificité outre-mer permet aujourd'hui
aux jeunes mères de poursuivre une
formation au sein du SMA avec des locaux
qui leur sont dédiés également un
accompagnement pour pour garder leurs
enfants pendant leur formation et on
sait que plus de 80% des jeunes qui
sortent du SMMA ont ensuite un débouché
favorable donc peuvent effectivement
avoir un emploi donc il faut multiplier
ces formations qui permettent
effectivement de concilier la vie de
jeune mère ou quelquefois de jeunes
paires avec avec ces formations qui
permettent ensuite d'avoir un accès à
l'emploi dans les dans l'eau dans la
panoplie d'outils il faut également nous
pourrions également citer lundi qui
permet d'accompagner en particulier de
nombreux projets de femmes et de jeunes
mères pour pour avoir pour un projet
professionnel pour une création pour une
création d'entreprise il faut aussi donc
multiplier les initiatives pour traiter
tous les l'ensemble des problèmes que
j'ai pour les que j'ai simplement pour
lesquelles j'ai simplement donné
un extrait sans doute pour les lettrisme
l'électronisme
l'Agence Nationale de Lutte contre la
contre l'illettrisme développe un
certain nombre d'outils des
diagnostics et qu'il faut coupler avec
davantage de formation tout au long de
la vie de tout au long de la vie
professionnelle tout en de la vie de la
vie de l'individu
s'agissant de la lutte contre la vie
contre la vie chère notre notre Ministre
délégué monsieur caraco a été auditionné
par la mission de l'Assemblée nationale
de lutte contre contre la vie chère et
la pub donné à cet homme de pistes à
travers le bouclier qualité prix qui
permet de d'avoir une stabilité de prix
d'une année sur l'autre avec un panier
de plus en plus étendu de produits et
puis également quelques pistes sur
l'octroi de mer parce que nous ne sommes
rendus compte que l'octroi de mer taxé
souvent des produits finalement de
première nécessité pour les parents à
l'entrée avec des taux parfois qui
peuvent atteindre entre 20% dans
certains territoires par exemple sur les
petits pots pour bébé ou
sur d'autres d'autres éléments
nécessaires à l'hygiène à l'hygiène des
enfants donc il est aussi important
d'agir sur ce sur ce volet sur ce volet
prix et puis enfin aussi bien sûr il
convient d'aider c'est ses parents ou
ses jeunes maires à s'insérer dans la
société et l'aspect effectivement le
soutien aux associations et
particulièrement important j'y
reviendrai j'y reviendrai ensuite
s'agissant de la partie propre on peut
dire au sens strict du mot du mot
soutien la parentalité effectivement des
les actions les actions publiques ont
été largement rappelées par ma collègue
de la DGCS notamment au travers les
initiatives des 1000 premiers jours
effectivement nous étions déjà
rapprochés de nos collègues aussi pour
adapter encore plus sans doute le livret
le
des conseils peut-être le pack aussi qui
est remis qui est remis aux jeux de mer
à la maternité donc il s'agit d'adapter
et d'adapter ses dater cette politique
comme d'adapter l'ensemble des
politiques je me sens particulièrement
importante d'avoir des volets outre-mer
dans des grandes stratégies publiques
dans les grands plans publics c'est le
cas par exemple pour la stratégie
nationale santé sexuelle 2017-2030 où il
y a des objectifs
ambitieux pour les outre-mer notamment
en termes de prévention de contraception
d'accès à cet homme d'informations pour
la stratégie nationale de soutien à la
parentalité il y a également un axe
important dédié dédié aux outre-mer avec
des actions des actions
des actions particulières et ciblées
notamment pour améliorer la connaissance
des besoins des familles donc il y a eu
avec le avec notre notre soutien et le
soutien du secrétariat d'État à la
protection de en 2019 nous avons
subventionné la production par
l'Université de Paris Nanterre d'une
revue de littérature donc qui constitue
maintenant une base documentaire unique
sur l'éducation et la famille des
Outre-mer un axe aussi été dédié en
possibilité d'accompagnement répondant
aux besoins spécifiques des outre-mer et
dans le cadre de cet axe nous avons
soutenu une association qui s'appelle
idéal co pour l'animation d'un réseau
professionnel
ultramarin sur les thématiques des
politiques jeunesse et la mise en place
aussi de plateformes d'échanges pour
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des outre-mer
et puis bien sûr il y avait aussi des
actions très importantes sur le ce qu'on
appelle l'allée vera aller vers les
parents dans notamment dans les
territoires isolés et des initiatives
ont pu être rappelées aussi par Monsieur
bedon en la matière pour pour la CNAF
sur sur ces pour aller
pour aller sur quelques unes de vos
questions madame la Présidente
s'agissant du non recours effectivement
les actions publiques se ce
effectivement vont de plus en plus sur
cette chaussette thématique nous avons
je peux également citer le
expérimentation zéro non recours qui
effectivement actuellement est en phase
de réception des candidatures de
ministère des outre-mer par
l'intermédiaire des préfets a essayé de
susciter des candidatures ultramarines
dans le cadre de cette appel à
manifestation d'intérêt et donc il y a
plusieurs de nombreuses candidatures
ultramarines qui sont en cours d'examen
bien sûr nous formons le jeu qu'elle
soit de pour certaines en déclaré
recevables et puissent participer à
cette à cette expérimentation les taux
sont particulièrement élevés bien sûr en
Guyane et à Mayotte sur ce non recours
avec bien sûr un effet comme j'indiquais
tout à l'heure
un effet fort illettrisme et un effet
aussi langue langue locale et donc il
est très important de pouvoir traduire
bien sûr le plus possible les documents
les interfaces les interfaces
informatiques il est important aussi de
développer les les maisons françaises il
y a un objectif de développement des
maisons françaises qui étaient assignées
aux outre-mer par l'intermédiaire de la
NCT et qui atteint déjà ses premiers ses
premiers objectifs ne pourront donner
quelques chiffres dans dans le dans le
dans le questionnaire
[Musique]
dans cette dans cet aspect aussi recours
aux prestations diverses effectivement
le s'agissant des prestations
familiales mais les prestations de
restauration scolaire qui sont très
importants pour pour l'enfant
l'existence de la partse outremare a été
cité par Monsieur bedon nous avons
également mené une action pour la Guyane
et Mayotte que nous pourrons décrire
dans le document qui a consisté encore à
réduire le reste à charge pour les
familles donc c'est une action qui a été
menée en lien avec nos collègues des
ministères sociaux un décret de paru en
décembre 2022 et qui réduit encore pour
Mayotte et pour la Guyane reste à charge
pour maillot de pour les repas du midi
et pour la Guyane pour les pour les pour
les collations donc c'est un
il me semble effectivement une voix
importante à suivre de d'observer de
continuer à observer et sans doute de de
tirer des enseignements de cette de
l'augmentation de la part pour essayer
de d'atteindre la cible précise que nous
avions assigné
s'agissant
s'agissant de de la poursuite de des
alignements des Outre-mer sur l'hexagone
en matière de prestation monsieur bedon
a pu indiquer que voilà les différences
étaient aujourd'hui très faibles il en
existe néanmoins vous avez cité donc le
coefficient familial et puis également
les prestations à Mayotte
s'agissant du
coefficient familial de complément
familial pardon s'agissant du complément
familial effectivement nous avons eu des
échanges pour refaire un point avec nos
collègues des ministères sociaux sur ce
sur cette prestation qui a aujourd'hui
est vraiment très très spécifique
puisque outre-mer elle elle s'applique
est difficile aux familles pour les
trois ans de l'enfant jusqu'au jusqu'au
4 ans révolu de l'enfant jusqu'au
jusqu'à la 5ème jusqu'au jusqu'au 5e
anniversaire donc ce cela veut dire que
effectivement c'est cette prestation
outre-mer donc on peut dire avantage les
familles monoparentales ou avec deux
enfants puisque cette prestation
n'existe pas dans l'Hexagone mais à
contrario voilà pour les familles
nombreuses elles s'arrête elle s'arrête
au cinquième anniversaire de l'enfant et
donc effectivement elle accompagne pas
ensuite les familles donc si s'il y
avait une voilà s'il y avait une réforme
de cette de ce complément familial va
les faire très attention sans doute
cette cette équilibre et à effectivement
au cible qu'on peut qu'on peut assigner
qu'on peut assigner à cette à ce
complément familial et faire très
attention aux familles aujourd'hui qui
bénéficient pour les familles de 2-1 ou
deux un ou deux enfants
s'agissant de Mayotte et des las du
chemin qui reste encore à parcourir sur
la convergence sociale le président de
la République a annoncé l'heure de sa
campagne d'un campagne présidentielle
qui souhaitait ramener le terme de la
convergence sociale de 2036 à
2031 donc ça veut dire accélérer cette
cette convergence qui est déjà a été
bien entamé puisque de nombreuses
prestations d'ores et déjà été alignées
néanmoins il existe encore des
différences majeures qui peuvent encore
effectivement qui peuvent concerner des
familles notamment s'agissant des
minimas sociaux les minima sociaux sont
RSA ou à location à location adultes
handicapés par exemple ou également
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
prestation effectivement complément
complément pour de compléments pour pour
l'exercice avec l'exercice un métier ce
ces prestations sont à la moitié de des
valeurs des valeurs nationales il y a
une difficulté puisqu'en fait on a aussi
outre en Mayotte un SMIC qui est
équivalent à SMIC qui est équivalent en
75% de sa valeur de sa valeur hexagonale
ça veut dire qu'effectivement c'est tout
un équilibre qu'il faut trouver entre un
accroissement du SMIC une croissance une
croissance économique et puis aussi une
croissance des prestations qui ne
peuvent pas voilà la croissance des
prestations ne peut pas anticiper
le développement économique et le et
aussi l'accroissement du SMIC donc c'est
tout un tout une réflexion d'ensemble
qu'il faut mener qu'il faut mener sur
ces sur ces minima sociaux sur les
dernières prestations sociales
effectivement qu'il convient qu'il
convient aussi de d'étudier et pour cet
équilibre pour ce pour mener cet
équilibre voilà il y a toute tout un
travail qui qui doit être mené en lien
en lien avec les ministères sociaux et
l'ensemble des ministères concernés
ministère de l'Économie et ministère
ministère ministère du Travail
voilà pour
pour Mayotte
[Musique]
notre notre réponse à la donnera aussi
quelques éléments d'explications que
vous avez souhaité même si ces éléments
d'explication ne sont pas complet sur
quelques effectivement quelques éléments
statistiques relatifs aux familles aux
familles des outre-mer et des raisons
pour lesquelles peut-être il y a une un
nombre important de grossesse précoce
j'ai cité quelques facteurs sur la
pauvreté la formation sur qui sont
vraiment des des grandes politiques
auxquelles le gouvernement
s'attaque aussi également en parallèle
donc c'est tout un front de politique
publique il faut qu'il faut mener pour
améliorer la situation de ces de ces
familles outre-mer je suis aussi bien
sûr à la votre disposition pour pour
compléter ses propos
merci beaucoup à vous quatre des propos
qui se sont complétés au fur et à mesure
de cette table ronde je vais puisque je
préside la délégation droit des femmes
mais vous l'avez compris c'est un
travail que nous menons avec le
président Stéphane Artano avec nos deux
délégations entre mère et droits des
femmes et donc je vais lui laisser
peut-être comme il préside il cumulent
en plus il préside et il est rapporteur
donc je vais le laisser peut-être
vous poser quelques questions mais
d'ores et déjà vous remercier puisque
j'aurais peut-être des questions aussi
complémentaires à la suite et je
laisserai bien entendu les collègues qui
sont présents avec nous ce matin
aussi vous adressez quelques questions
puisque j'imagine que vos propos ou vont
faire réagir à vous chers collègues qui
vous êtes levés très tôt monsieur le
président
merci merci pour tous ces éclairages
j'ai pas beaucoup de questions il y en a
au moins une adresse à la DGCS
concernant la seconde feuille de route
que vous avez indiquée en cours de
rédaction sur les 1000 premiers jours à
quelle échéance est-ce que vous prévoyez
la sortir ça c'est la première question
la deuxième question touche
essentiellement le soutien la
parentalité mais n'est pas dirigé
d'ailleurs mais elle concerne évidemment
la CAF me semble-t-il
puisque les acteurs ont entendu au cours
de nos travaux en souligné évidemment
l'action des cases ont été étroits tout
en déplorant effectivement des
financements qui interviennent
essentiellement par des appels à projets
donc l'idée c'était de voir un peu de
quelle manière finalement des
financements soient structurels plus
réelles en direction des associations
pouvaient être envisagées ou pas et ça
rejoint d'ailleurs la question numéro 13
que du gestionnaire qui consiste à dire
dans quelles conditions finalement les
fédérations et des associations
nationales des acteurs de soutien à la
parentalité pourraient être plus
présente dans les outre-mer en fait on
essaie de réfléchir à la manière qui
permettrait de faire en sorte que ces
acteurs puissent être pour vous
également des relais plus importants
encore sur les territoires il y a des
fédérations notamment une que j'avais
rencontrées qui me disait ne pas
disposer de relais forcément sur tous
nos territoires ultramarins et donc on
essaie de réfléchir à la manière la plus
efficace et efficiente pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit justement des relais
pour la parenthèse sur le territoire et
puis pour vous institutionnels dont le
déploiement de certaines politiques
publiques j'en ai terminé j'ai un
président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
vous laisse peut-être vous organiser ce
qui souhaitent répondre aux présidents
Stéphane Artano
oui monsieur le Président pour répondre
sur la suite de la deuxième feuille de
route des 1000 premiers jours elle est
en cours d'élaboration il doit y avoir
encore une phase de donc d'élaboration
et de concertation et l'objectif est de
pouvoir la publier on va dire d'ici la
rentrée de 2023 donc dans quelques dans
quelques mois au maximum parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle est attendue et dans la
déclinaison la feuille de route ça
permet de répondre en partie à des
questions aussi que vous posiez sur le
sujet des appels à projets parce que là
en 2023 l'instruction appelle à projet
1000 premiers jours et est en cours là
quasiment de publication je crois que
c'est elle va apparaître dans les
prochains jours et c'est vrai que la le
sujet du pluriel et de la manière dont
on peut mobiliser les acteurs sur sur
des financements plus structurels et
étant en question en tout cas on a un
fond innovation qui est aussi qui va
être publié dans dans les prochains
jours en lien avec les différents
partenaires notamment la CNAF en
particulier avec l'idée d'être sur par
exemple plus rien n'était trois ans ce
qui répond en partie à ces soucis on va
dire que nous ferons remonter les les
associations après se pose la question
de plus structurelle donc notamment les
sur les maisons des 1000 premiers jours
et Maison des familles on doit pouvoir
réfléchir à des à des financements qui
sont la plus structurelles et qui
rentrent dans le cas de la notamment de
la cause Fnac ça fait partie des
discussions en cours pour finaliser le
l'atterrissage on va dire de la de la
cause et notamment du Fnac au sein de
cette cage avec la CNAV
oui monsieur Benoît
je sais pas si j'ai besoin de rajouter
des choses concernant concernant les
financements et la plus rainuité
on est tout à fait d'accord il y a des
discussions en cours effectivement sur
le sujet
qui nous permettront ou non
effectivement de nous inscrire dans ce
dans ce besoin de plus réanualité de et
de de de
structuration et en tout cas on comprend
bien le besoin d'un syndrome
d'associations pour autant il faut faire
la distinction entre ce qui relève d'une
action ponctuelle ou d'un projet
innovant sur lequel effectivement
en bon gestionnaire on a envie de dire
que on met un peu au pot enfin les caves
participent mais mais pour voir
finalement ce qu'il en est du sujet et
si le projet effectivement tient la
route économiquement et au regard de ces
objectifs sociaux et ensuite à des fonds
qui eux sont assis sur sur une base
contractuelle qui de toute façon
inscrite d'emblée la plus réanualité sur
la production d'un service voilà donc
mais effectivement je pense qu'il y a un
segment associatif qui répond qui par sa
souplesse réponse aussi à des urgences à
des innovations à des besoins nouveaux
qui émergent et qui a besoin d'être
accompagné en tout cas dans sa dans si
la réponse apportée correspond
effectivement aux besoins qui a besoin
d'être accompagné ensuite dans une
structuration plus pérenne ça c'est
entendu
alors dans le prolongement par rapport à
la question de là aussi de la
mobilisation peut-être souhaiter autour
des des réseaux nationaux qui
accompagnent donc leur associations
leurs opérateurs locaux sur les
territoires
la Caisse nationale a accompagne chaque
année
de 74 78 par nom association nationale
têtes de réseau association nationale
parmi ces 78 on a identifié que il y en
avait une cinquantaine qui est
effectivement ont des antennes ont des
implantations sur les territoires
d'outre-mer donc on les soutient alors
essentiellement pour pour leur permettre
de financer leur action de têtes de
réseau d'animation de structuration de
leur réseau de d'outillage de ressources
méthodologiques techniques métiers
législatif etc sur le monde associatif
et le secteurs d'intervention dans
lesquelles ils interviennent mais
effectivement durant la l'actuel période
c'est-à-dire 2018-2022 on a souhaité
avec ces associations qui est qui
étaient implantées sur les territoires
d'outre-mer aller un peu plus loin que
que simplement soutenir l'animation
globale de leur réseau mais les investir
d'une mission de vraiment
d'accompagnement de proximité auprès de
ces territoires et je pense
particulièrement à la Fédération
nationale des centres sociaux qui a été
un partenaire fort qui est un partenaire
historique de la branche famille de
toute façon mais qui a effectivement
vraiment jouer le jeu et bon on l'a
accompagné financièrement aussi mais qui
s'est vraiment fortement investi sur ce
sujet pour
premièrement pour pour créer et de pour
faire émerger des des structures les
centres sociaux des espaces de vie
sociale mais aussi pour construire et
créer une instance départementale qui
sera en capacité ensuite
d'animer sur le département et
d'accompagner sur le département
l'ensemble des centres sociaux qui se
seront créés et ça on a vraiment un
besoin effectivement il y a un segment
intermédiaire entre le National et le
très local de passer à une échelle
départementale d'accompagnement des
opérateurs alors je parle des centres
sociaux mais ça pourrait être
l'ensemble des structures le petit
enfance bon l'organisation est peut-être
déjà un peu plus un peu plus avancé de
ce côté là et et par le biais des
schémas des services aux familles par
exemple mais il y a beaucoup de secteurs
d'activité où il y a beaucoup de choses
qui se font par de multiples réseaux
mais il manque une échelle de
coordination d'animation et
d'accompagnement méthodologique métier
technique
et de formation des professionnels au
quotidien et en routine voilà donc on va
essayer sur l'aide sur cette base là
dans la prochaine convention objective
on a effectivement l'objectif si si
l'ensemble de ces projets là sont sont
validés dans nos discussions avec l'État
on a vraiment le souhait pour les
outre-mer de de renforcer cette
mobilisation des des têtes de résonation
nationale de manière à ce qu'elle puisse
en local se mobiliser davantage et
construire de de l'animation et de la
coordination au niveau des départements
merci beaucoup madame monsieur pour
pour ces réponses aux questions du
président Artano peut-être compléter
aussi les questions du Président vous
avez parlé madame Morvan Paris tout à
l'heure d'expérimentation à la fois en
Guyane à la Réunion notamment avec un
référent natalité et le parcours
naissance ces expérimentations
pourraient vous pouvez vous ce matin
vous pourrez-vous nous envoyer des
éléments plus précis à la fois sur
depuis quand elles ont été mises en
place est-ce que ce sont des moyens
supplémentaires qui vous sont qui sont
alloués et pourquoi ces deux territoires
commencent s'articulent ces
expérimentations dans le dispositif
existant vous nous avez également fait
part de staff médico-sociaux avec un
budget si je me suis pas trompé dans mon
c'est ma prise de notes parfois
anarchique de 400.000 euros en 2021 je
crois et de 200.000 euros ensuite donc
ça peut paraître beaucoup mais ça
représente combien de personnes et à
l'échelle des territoires ultramarins ça
peut une fois qu'on divise ça peut
effectivement paraître peut-être un peu
ridicule c'est quand mon quand on parle
de milliards et qu'on ramène au nombre
de personnes ça peut parfois avoir une
échelle de d'appréciation différente
lorsque vous avez dit également congé
paternité une augmentation du recours on
a assez peu évoqué ce matin les les
familles monoparentales la non
reconnaissance des pères donc peut-être
que évidemment à partir du moment où
vous avez deux tiers des enfants qui
sont pas reconnus par les pairs dans
certains territoires j'imagine que ceux
qui reconnaissent leurs enfants leur
sont extrêmement motivés et donc ne
rentre pas dans le cadre
général de ce cette non reconnaissance
ensuite sur vous avez évoqué le parcours
des 1000 premiers jours avec la
nécessaire adaptation alors c'est vrai
que je suis assez quand même surprise
que on n'est pas imaginé
depuis la métropole une traduction
dans pour que ce soit compréhensible de
tous les parents en fait je trouve ça
c'est souvent lorsqu'on dit a besoin
d'avoir des choses en proximité et ça
fait écho aux ressources le cas que vous
avez évoqué donc est-ce que vous arrivez
à avoir des ressources locales Humaines
je parle et est-ce que vous formez des
personnes de plus en plus pour pouvoir
être au plus près du terrain ensuite
peut-être des questions aussi sur
à la fois les parcours que vous avez
évoqué monsieur bedon sur parcours
séparation parcours arrivés d'enfants
est-ce que c'est parcours sont mis en
place dans tous les territoires
d'outre-mer est-ce que c'est une
expérimentation également et si vous les
avez mis en place que dans certains
territoires
quels sont les raisons
et puis je pense que j'ai déjà posé
beaucoup de questions alors comme je
vois que vous notez les questions et que
peut-être que je vais céder la parole
aux deux sénatrice qui nous ont rejoint
Annick Pétrus sénatrice de Saint-Martin
et Micheline Jacques sénatrice de
Saint-Barth donc peut-être Annick Pétrus
si elle souhaite et comme ça vous notez
les questions vous pourrez nous répondre
parce qu'il y a peut-être des questions
qui se croiseront merci à vous pour ces
réponses une dernière sur l'IVG quand
même on en a assez peu parlé est-ce
qu'il y a des stratégies pour limiter le
nombre d'IVG est-ce que les stratégies
sont différentes selon les territoires
du fait de situations différentes merci
chers collègues
merci collègue de me donner la parole et
merci aux uns et les autres pour le
reclairage sur cette problématique alors
comme la annoncé ma collègue je suis la
sénatrice du de la collectivité
territoriale de Saint-Martin une
collectivité qui a 17 ans cette année
pour avoir occupé le poste de 3e
vice-présidente en charge justement de
ces affaires là je sais
et les chiffres prononcés et par
Monsieur bedon aujourd'hui ne m'étonne
pas d'autant que les territoires
d'outre-mer ont souvent été pointés du
doigt et ça continue comme des
consommateurs de voilà de la caisse
d'allocation familiale et que nous
étions les champions en consommation de
ces aides là je vais pas revenir dessus
je suppose que cette réponse a déjà été
donnée c'est la situation sociale des
territoires et surtout de ses habitants
qui font que aujourd'hui
vous avez des gens qui n'ont pas
d'autres possibilités que de chercher à
vivre de ces aides là puisque n'ayant
pas n'ayant pas de travail voilà et des
fois ça se ça se reproduit de génération
génération j'ai vu maman faire maman a
vécu avec les allocations familiales
avec les aides sociales de toutes sortes
chaque 3 ans maman faisait un bébé pour
ne pas perdre le bénéfice du montant et
aujourd'hui nous avons des jeunes qui
reproduisent le même schéma non pas
parce qu'ils ont trouvé une façon de
vivre mais parce qu'ils ont pas trouvé
d'autres façons de vivre parce que dès
lors qu'ils ont une autre possibilité
ils arrivent à s'en sortir donc ça c'est
dit et je suppose que ça a été dit tout
au long des auditions que vous avez
aujourd'hui
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que nous étions
une jeune collectivité il y a 6 mois que
la collectivité de Saint-Martin a signé
avec la Caisse d'Allocations Familiales
ce qu'on appelle le pti le plan
territorial d'insertion et le
CDG je crois que c'est la convention
territoriale globale
c'est pour dire que des fois les
collectivités ne sont pas toujours
informés de tous les dispositifs
existants au sein de la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales moi je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure et j'ai présidé
une délégation et c'est au fur et à
mesure que je découvrais mais tiens on
peut faire ça des dispositifs qu'on
pourrait mettre en place pour aider
des familles
la plupart du temps monoparentale
à embrasser autrement le la parentalité
nous avons par exemple les bénéficiaires
des RSA
il y a pas longtemps que j'ai appris que
il pouvait avoir des aides de de pour
faire garder leur enfant le temps d'une
je sais pas un entretien d'embauche ou
un temps pour aller chercher du travail
cette information là je n'ai pas eu
quand j'étais vice-présidente en charge
parce que sinon il y a des choses qu'on
aurait pu mettre en place très
rapidement pour que ces aides là ne
soient peut-être pas versé directement
au BRSA
mais que ce soit versé par exemple à des
structures ou des associations qui
accompagneraient ces familles là dans la
garde de leur enfant pourquoi je dis ça
parce que il y a aussi beaucoup de
détournement d'aide
et ça éviterait que que certaines zones
notamment de la location familiale soit
détournée
rentrée scolaire alors c'est pas
systématiquement détourné
dans une autre vie j'ai été directrice
d'un établissement scolaire et je peux
vous dire que ces aides de rentrée
scolaire ne sont pas toujours à 100%
utilisé pour l'enfant
les allocations familiales non plus
d'ailleurs
vous avez des enfants qui durent
du premier au 15 du mois
sont bien lotis ils ont un goûter on
sent que bon voilà et à partir du 15 du
mois ils ont plus de goûter parce que
voilà l'argent est fini donc nouvelle
gestion des familles là aussi
donc je vous je vous livre comme ça en
bloc toutes les difficultés qu'on voit
et est-ce que on ne pourrait pas au sein
de la CAF alors j'ai compris que la
carte ne peut pas aider à la gestion des
allocations familiales mais trouver des
dispositifs par le biais de structure
peut-être d'association je sais pas
d'utilité publique qui pourrait aider
les familles
dernièrement j'ai demandé au pôle
solidarité famille que nous ayons à
disposition de ces familles là des
conseillers
social familiales ou économique
familiale j'ai oublié le terme pour
pouvoir les accompagner
c'est des familles qui vont remplir le
frigo les 15 premiers jours avec
l'argent des allocations familiales les
enfants vont tout manger en 15 jours et
après il y aura plus d'argent et ils
viendront à l'école sans goûter sans
ceci sans cela donc aider comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait mettre en place des
dispositifs pour aider à la bonne
utilisation de cette là parce que la CAF
joue son rôle la CAF donne mais la
gestion de cet argent ne permet pas
puisque nous sommes dans le domaine de
la parentalité ne permet pas aux parents
d'embrasser convenablement leur mission
le rôle et l'utilisation de ces fonds là
alors nous avons expérimenté sur le
territoire de Saint-Martin au lendemain
de l'ouragan Irma
qu'un dispositif qu'on a appelé carte
cohésion alors je sais que
certaines disent que c'est un peu
très très en adéquation avec la
Constitution est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
par exemple
initier des partenariats des conventions
avec
tout ce qui est libre
et qu'une partie de ces aides là ne soit
pas donné sous forme de carte pour être
sûr que ça va être dépensé dans ce cadre
là et non pas pour embouter les traite
de voiture etc etc je dis n'importe quoi
j'essaye de voir ce qui peut être fait
dans ce domaine là mais aujourd'hui je
crois que la plus grande problématique
que nous avons sur le territoire
c'est l'utilisation
de de ces aides sociales et notamment
donné par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales alors j'ai une stigmatise pas
tout le monde vous avez des familles qui
s'affairent qui font bien vous avez un
trop gros pourcentage de famille qui
font délibérément mal parce que les
aides sont détournées et d'autres qui
font mal parce qu'elles ne savent pas
faire elles sont livrées elles-mêmes
voilà je voulais dire des enfants tous
les trois ans moi je viens par un élève
qui me l'a dit un parent d'élèves qui
m'a dit que chaque toison elle est
obligée de faire de refaire un bébé
parce que elle perd l'aide du précédent
et c'est un fonctionnement qui est comme
ça donc je pense que il y a une prise en
charge au niveau de ces familles à faire
alors c'est pas à vous la caisse
d'allocation familiale mais voir avec
les collectivités ce qui pourrait être
fait alors déjà apporté l'information de
tout ce que vous vous proposez parce que
je me suis rendu compte que la caisse
d'allocations familiales iale avait un
panel de
dispositifs qui peuvent être mis en
place alors des des informations des
journées portes ouvertes que ce soit
pour l'usager que pour les collectivités
surtout les collectivités comme la
mienne par exemple qui ont qui sont
jeunes on va dire
et et donc c'est quand même le
compétences et au niveau des
prestations voir ensemble ce qui peut
être fait pour que ces prestations là
puissent être utilisées convenablement
et que l'enfant
qui est en fait le principal
bénéficiaire puisse en bénéficier
convenablement voilà c'est un peu le vœu
que je formule ce matin alors c'est une
réflexion ça fait un moment que des gens
parlent ça c'est de notoriété publique
que les aides sociales et notamment la
Caisse d'Allocations Familiales
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait pour
que ces enfants là et ces familles là
puissent vivre convenablement de ce qui
est donné parce que en face vous avez la
Caisse d'Allocations familiale qui fait
des efforts financiers qui qui pour que
des enfants vivent bien au sein de leur
famille et c'est pas toujours le cas
voilà merci beaucoup chers collègues
pour ce témoignage qui forcément est en
prise directe avec la réalité de ce que
vous pouvez vivre à Saint-Martin où nous
sommes d'ailleurs rendus avec notre
collègue Micheline Jacques donc
sénatrice de Saint-Barth et qui va aussi
vous interroger si elle le souhaite
tout a été dit je sais pas tu te
souhaites pas forcément de bonnes
questions précises non papa
immédiatement donc je vais vous laisser
répondre à toutes ces questions monsieur
et mesdames donc à la fois mes questions
et je l'ai complètement par peut-être le
contrat d'objectif les délais pas plus
pour la CAF en fait comment vous
organisez
c'était une question je crois du
Sénateur rapporteur président Stéphane
Artano sur le contrat d'objectifs
madame Morvan Paris oui madame la
Présidente vous m'aviez posé la question
de ce qui était exactement les parcours
natalité les staffs
médico-psychosociaux qui peuvent se
mettre en place et de quelle manière en
fait il se pour pourquoi certains
territoires le font pas d'autres en fait
aujourd'hui sur une une expérimentation
donc c'est un appel en fait à
candidature un arrêté d'expérimentation
il se trouve que la Guyane a été retenue
sur cette
expérimentation pour la mise en place
notamment de de référent parcours et
donc l'idée de ce référence et
d'accompagner au mieux des personnes qui
sont repérées comme vulnérable puisqu'il
y a trois moments importants à c'est
l'entretien précoce prénatal le temps de
la maternité ce qui se passe pendant la
voilà l'accouchement et les quelques
jours ensuite puis le retour au domicile
et c'est donc d'avoir un étayage d'avoir
une présence en fait de professionnels
pour que le lien parce que c'est en fait
la base de la du consensus qu'il y a eu
sur les 1000 premiers jours c'est que ce
lien d'attachement doit se faire au
mieux dès le dès l'arrivée de l'enfant
pour que ensuite le parent assume
pleinement son rôle de parents même en
difficulté sociale parce que l'idée
c'est évidemment que on peut être on
peut être un bon parent dans tout
contexte social mais que ce lien
d'attachement est primordial et donc
c'est à la fois de trouver les
ressources personnelles et accompagner
la maman notamment pour pour être
capable de pouvoir élever son enfant
avec des bons à la fois des conseils de
je dirais d'ordre matériel mais aussi
sur le jeu sur le regard enfin voilà
c'est c'est des aussi des temps
d'observation il staff
médico-psychosocial c'est la même idée
c'est à dire de pouvoir en tout cas que
les équipes de professionnels et là
c'est des moyens de renforce en fait les
moyens notamment de présence de
personnels médicaux et paramédicaux au
sein des maternités pour faire du
repérage de personnes que là qui se
rendent peut-être pas forcément compte
d'elle-même et qui sont vraiment en
situation fragilité sur lesquels on sait
que le retour au domicile va pouvoir
être très compliqué on est aussi dans de
la prévention avant la protection de
l'enfance à clairement ça rentre aussi
dans l'idée que il faut soutenir au plus
fort et au plus vite avant de rentrer
dans des dispositifs qui relèvent qui
sont hors du droit commun et qui sont
dans la protection de l'enfance et donc
c'est staffs se sont développés
l'idée c'est de pouvoir à terme en tout
cas on était sur une partie
expérimentale mais c'est que chaque
maternité puisse en bénéficier puisque
on sait que ce repérage et ce dialogue
entre professionnel avec ensuite la PMI
qui peut revenir au domicile quand elle
sait qu'il y a eu des signaux permet en
fait de d'assurer une meilleure en tout
cas prise en compte des difficultés
parentales
soit non reconnaissances pourquoi au
niveau de l'outre-mer en tout cas de
certains territoires les pères ne
reconnaissent pas leur enfance j'ai pas
d'analyse je pense qu'il y a eu des
études et sociologiques et je crois
qu'au niveau en tout cas ministériel j'y
crois qu'on voit si on a des éléments à
vous apporter sur d'éventuelles études
en tout cas si c'est pas le cas ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'on y travaille c'est
collectivement pour accompagner cette
cette place du père qui est pour nous un
des grands objets de la future
stratégie des 1000 jours c'est que on a
un peu trop oublié la place des pères
dans la précédente feuille de route et
que le congé paternité est un outil mais
pas seulement
on sait que y compris en protection de
l'enfance la place des deux parents et
importante et il faut qu'on soit plus
attentif en fait à la reconnaissance de
la place du père auprès de l'enfant et
qui aussi sera un soutien
auprès de de la maman si il y a eu
séparation par exemple et pour le coup
la CNAF a développé de nombreux outils
autour de la séparation et de
l'accompagnement des familles sur ces
sur ces moments là
sur l'IVG c'est les collègues de la
santé on vous répondra de manière plus
particulière parce qu'ils sont pas
présents ce matin mais on a certains
éléments qu'on pourra vous apporter sur
des éléments de par la Direction
générale de la santé qui qui a un effet
déployé un certain nombre de programmes
donc on pourra vous apporter les
précisions utiles dans le document
sur les parcours mais rapidement oui
nous sommes sur des dispositifs qui sont
construits pour le coup qui sont dans le
champ de l'intervention sociale et donc
ils sont à la main de de de du conseil
d'administration de la cnaval et des
conseils d'administration des cafs en
concertation bien entendu avec avec les
services de l'État mais mais nous sommes
dans nous sommes dans le champ de
l'extra légal d'accord donc c'est un peu
nous qui définissons finalement les
périmètres et là on est sur
effectivement un périmètre qui est
construit pour l'ensemble du réseau des
caisses d'allocations familiales y
compris et avoir Suri bien entendu les
cinq départements d'outre-mer voilà et
donc sur le parcours et d'ailleurs et on
prend on prend attache des notamment des
Outre-mer dès qu'on le peut et le
parcours séparation qui est qui a été
mis en place en 2000 en 2021
a fait l'objet d'une phase
d'expérimentation en amont qui a associé
la cave de la Martinique le parcours le
parcours arrivait de l'enfant qui va se
qui va se déployer fin d'année début
d'année prochaine lui aussi a fait
l'objet d'une phase expérimentation qui
cette fois-ci a associé la cave de la
Réunion voilà on essaye effectivement
parce qu'on a bien identifié les
particularités et et on a un peu
tendance à construire du National vers
le local avec une prégnance globalement
de ce que l'on sait des besoins des
territoires de 90% des territoires et
des fois malheureusement on va un peu
trop vite on oubliant des particularités
qui sont propres à des mécanismes ou des
réalités sociales des Outre-mer c'est
pour ça qu'on essaye dès qu'on le peut
quand on mène des expérimentations
d'inscrire d'emblée les territoires
d'outre-mer de manière à ce qu'il nous
apporte et qui nous alerte s'il y a un
moment donné on va trop vite on oublie
quelque chose voilà pour faire en sorte
que le cadre national qui sera construit
soit suffisamment inclusif et prennent
en compte effectivement la réalité ou
les réalités sociales les outre-mer
pour ce qui est alors j'ai pas de
réponse particulière sur sur
intervention madame mais juste ça fait
écho alors je prends je prends bien note
de
certainement de l'amélioration de la
communication à à construire
vis-à-vis des institutions vis-à-vis des
partenaires vis-à-vis des allocataires
et mes vis-à-vis des partenaires je
pense que parce que
les problématiques que vous posez elles
existent chez vous elles existent aussi
dans le 93 enfin partout en France
de savoir comment les parents utilisent
effectivement les les allocations
familiales et autres prestations
familiales ou sociales qui leur sont
versées
je crois que là ça renvoie effectivement
à la nécessité
impérieuse d'avoir des des associations
relais auprès de ces familles des
travailleurs sociaux vous pointiez les
les conseillères en économie sociale et
familiale qui ont un rôle autour
justement de la question de la gestion
budgétaire des familles
malheureusement je pense que sur
certains territoires c'est c'est corps
intermédiaires relay de l'information et
de l'accompagnement des familles sont en
sont en nombre insuffisant
on est également confronté une pénurie
dans le domaine social en général des
professionnels et voilà j'ai pas de
réponse mais je j'entends bien ce que
vous dites et voilà
ensuite vous aviez une question
concernant les contrats le contrat
d'objectif et de gestion d'accord
la caisse d'accord
la Caisse nationale tous les ans depuis
depuis une petite vingtaine d'années
maintenant
contractualise tous les 5 ans avec
l'État
ces orientations et les moyens qui
permettent de mettre en oeuvre ses
orientations et donc on vient de
terminer la précédente convention
d'objectifs et de gestion puis qui
courait sur les années 2018-2022 on a
fait un travail interne avec l'ensemble
de notre réseau pour pour faire le bilan
de cette période et construire les
projeter sur les orientations qui seront
les prochaines donc 2023 2027 et nous
sommes en pleine phase de négociation
avec avec l'État sur bien sûr l'ensemble
de nos champs d'intervention d'action
sociale mais de relation de service
d'outillage de système d'information de
de services des prestations et du
fonctionnement de notre réseau voilà
peut-être un petit point nous avons dans
le cadre de cette discussion avec l'État
comme nous l'avions organisé sur la
précédente période une fiche spécifique
dédiée aux outre-mer alors loin de nous
le souhait de vouloir extraire du réseau
national les outre-mer mais il nous a
semblé alors l'équipe de travers bien
entendu bénéficient de l'ensemble des
outils leviers de financement
cadre contractuel et il le réclame
d'ailleurs de nationaux mais il nous a
néanmoins sembler qu'il était nécessaire
de mettre en lumière des des conditions
et des contextes un peu particuliers et
peut-être des actions un peu un peu
particulières également en termes de de
vigilance et de renforcement de la
Caisse nationale vis-à-vis des Outre-mer
voilà
bien merci merci beaucoup j'ai peut-être
une dernière question vous pourrez
peut-être pas forcément me répondre ce
sera peut-être comme sur la santé mais
je voudrais savoir comment les acteurs
institutionnels
prennent en compte l'adoption coutumière
qui est fréquente dans certains
territoires comme la Polynésie ou les
sociétés Canac est-ce que comment
gérez-vous
la parentalité dans ce cadre là qui est
un cadre exceptionnel
je vais pouvoir répondre en quelques
mots mais je pense qu'il sera comme
c'est des sujets un peu
délicat au regard en fait des textes de
l'application au niveau de la métropole
un certain nombre de textes sur
l'adoption et vous savez qu'on est en
pleine en plus évolution en ce moment
sur des sur la manière dont on conçoit
l'adoption le Conseil national
d'adoption vient d'être installé là il y
a il y a 15 jours pour qui va notamment
en tout cas l'État va pouvoir lui
soumettre un certain de décret qui
décline de la loi de février 2022 qui a
revu un certain nombre d'items mais une
de nos questions c'est en effet
notamment sur la Polynésie l'application
d'une coutume en effet qui ne relève pas
aujourd'hui du champ réellement de
l'adoption qui ne peut pas être reconnu
en tout cas et qui pose des vraies
questions de filiation et de droit pour
l'enfant ensuite donc ce que je vous
propose c'est de vous répondre de par
écrit et de manière assez précise sur un
sujet qui en effet un peu un peu
complexe mais qui qui aussi par ailleurs
[Musique]
par rapport aux interventions notamment
sur le la question du réseau de
formation on apprend aussi de
l'outre-mer la manière dont l'action la
famille de l'entourage familial élargie
peut aussi être un soutien de l'enfant
donc je vais aussi peut-être faire une
autre aussi positive de ce qu'on peut
aussi retenir c'est à dire que on se
rend compte que en tout cas dans le cas
de la loi de la protection de l'enfance
la question de l'entourage en métropole
et pas assez regardée on va dire les
figures les figures d'attachement qui
sont hautes que celles des parents et en
tout cas on sait qu'en outre-mer il y a
ce il y a ce regard là il y a cette
possibilité de concevoir aussi la
famille de manière élargie et en tout
cas il faut que nous on réfléchisse à ne
pas venir en tout cas remettre en cause
un modèle avec notre regard purement
métropolitain mais en même temps
s'assurer des droits derrière parce
qu'il y a un vrai problème de droit
ensuite pour l'enfant et la famille
merci beaucoup Madame la Directrice
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on nous sommes la
délégation au droit des femmes enfin et
la délégation aux outre-mer mais
lorsqu'on gagne en égalité lorsqu'on
gagne des droits pour les femmes c'est
en fait on gagne pour la société pour
les hommes et pour les femmes donc je
suis persuadée que oui ces travaux que
nous menons avec la délégation aux
outre-mer
nous permettront probablement de fléchir
peut-être aussi des bonnes pratiques des
bonnes expérimentations qui pourront
être dupliquées parce que comme vous
l'avez souligné monsieur bedon des
difficultés qui ont été pointées par
notre collègue sénatrice de Saint-Martin
peuvent se retrouver dans d'autres
territoires sur l'hexagone donc je tiens
vraiment à vous remercier et peut-être
je vous laisserai un mode conclusion à
notre président à distance Stéphane
Artano à vous remercier sincèrement pour
la précision de vous répondre vous
renouvelez aussi le fait que vous pouvez
nous adresser par écrit des réponses
complémentaires ou des des dispositifs
précis qui sont mis en place et donc
avant le 12 juin si c'est possible
puisqu'on a besoin d'y travailler un
petit peu pour les intégrer à la fois
dans notre rapport et dans les
recommandations qui pourront être faites
et vous dire aussi à nouveau que je
m'excuse bien entendu les deux
rapporteurs qui étaient absentes pour
raison de médecins donc voilà tout
excusé pour cette raison et victoire
jasmin également donc nous ne sommes pas
tous malades mais la période est propice
entre les chevaux les froids et les
climatisations à des des virus pas très
sympathiques mais beaucoup plus
sympathique que la covid donc je vais
laisser le président Stéphane Artano
conclure et je vous en remercie
sincèrement
également les participants qui étaient
des territoires ultramarins mais nous
avions la Loire et la Saône-et-Loire
également qui était représentée merci
Bernard d'être
Bernard Fournier d'être avec nous aussi
ce matin
merci cher président merci Annick merci
madame monsieur mesdames de la qualité
de cette audition et puis des apports
que vous nous avez donc vous avez fait
part on voit bien que la matière est
quand même en mouvement au niveau
national notamment dans le cadre de la
discussion de la cause de la CNAV et moi
je suis très très preneur de voir de
quelle manière justement les
l'adaptations de la feuille de route y
compris des 1000 premiers jours pourra
avoir lieu en outre-mer puisque nous
plaidons au sein de notre délégation
mais je crois que c'est partagé au sein
du Sénat pour une différenciation de la
mise en oeuvre des politiques dans
chacun nos territoires pour tenir compte
de la sociologie des contextes
économiques et sociaux car rappelé
notamment Isabelle Richard en
particulier sur Mayotte c'est notamment
un élément évidemment fondamental à
avoir à l'esprit et donc on est vraiment
preneur de ces évolutions et de ce qui
guide vos réflexions et donc surtout
n'hésitez pas à nous faire part comme la
prison billon l'a dit de vos remarques
ou de tout apport que vous jugerez
utile et nécessaire par écrit au-delà de
l'audition et de la qualité de celle-ci
que nous avons aujourd'hui donc je te
rends le micro j'ai un président et en
tout cas merci à toutes et à tous pour
votre présence et votre participation
active merci au président et bonne fin
de nuit alors où lever je ne sais pas
parce que du coup vraiment il est très
courageux
tout à l'heure sur le foncier agricole
en outre-mer donc ça n'est pas fini ah
très bien bon ben au moins tu t'es pas
levé pour rien c'est ce qu'il faut voir
le côté positif toujours merci à vous
monsieur monsieur le sénateur et
mesdames pour votre participation et
bonne journée à tous et à toutes